an army of inspectors is working right
now to make sure you're not getting
ripped off while you're filling up at
the pump now last week our 8 news now
investigators tested gas quality at
stations all across the valley and now
our David Charn shows you how the
professionals do it what else they're
looking for though might surprise you
we test every station in the state of
Nevada
big job making sure what's going in your
tank is the result of a fair transaction
if you're pumping five gallons of fuel
that five gallons is actually five
gallons they'll pump within that range
Kip Lauer is a supervisor with the
division of measurement standards a team
of 10 inspectors in southern Nevada
testing each and every fuel pump before
it connects with your car the inspectors
go out if they're driving to a station
they feel like they haven't been there
they'll just pop in and say hi I'm here
the goal is for an inspector to check
each station once a year they'll also
head out if a consumer makes a complaint
the 8 news now investigators reviewed
all those complaints from last July to
this June when gas prices hit their Peak
out of more than 108 filed 35 involved
the accuracy of a pump's meter
oftentimes those mistakes are actually
in the customer's favor meter sets are
either given or fuel away or holding
fuel mostly it's given given fuel away
when it wears out it'll it'll go to the
benefit of the consumer out of those 35
meter relay related complaints
inspectors found just one pump one had a
problem the investigators tested 12 gas
stations for fuel quality finding no
issues in the samples we sent to two
Labs I haven't seen a water and gas scam
in the years that I've been with with
Department of Agriculture Blower's team
also goes out in test gas of each octane
for Quality out of the nearly 2500 fuel
samples taken over the past year 14
gasoline samples were out of compliance
with prices what they are today the team
is also looking at the price on the pump
and on that sign outside while there's
no time frame written into law for when
that sign has to change blower says the
prices can't be misleading if they know
that that fuel has been changed at the
pump and they just leave the sign out
there and not change it for you know a
day or so they're they're misleading the
general public out of 20 complaints nine
prices were quote inconsistent with 10
years on the job blower says he's never
come across a gas station purposely
defrauding its customers have we had
that not clearly where they are clearly
just saying that no we're not going to
follow your direction and we're going to
continue with selling we don't have that
the penalties are too high
keeping gas stations compliant and your
money safe one fill up at a time I'm
David charns 8 News Now